bueno hablamos ahora de economía está
conmigo en el estudio jorge hurtado para
darnos los detalles de este cierre de
semana jorge economía analizamos
entonces los resultados las
conversaciones del foro de davos durante
ese encuentro en suiza que dijeron allí
bueno como sabrá hace ahí se reunieron
los líderes empresariales con los
líderes políticos también del mundo
tratando de encontrar soluciones a estos
problemas que afectan a la economía
global la inflación la guerra en ucrania
los problemas en las cadenas de
suministro y la amenaza a la seguridad
alimentaria fueron los focos de este
encuentro aunque no hubo ninguna
declaración conjunta del inicio klaus
schwab el fundador de este foro emitió
que el mundo pasa por un momento crítico
con grandes desafíos en lo político
económico y por supuesto en la salud
este fuero no contó con la asistencia de
rusia y china- se excusó por su brote de
kobe 19a y la directora del fondo
monetario internacional kristalina
georgieva trató de disipar el pesimismo
asegurando que una recesión económica
mundial no está sobre la mesa pero
tampoco la descarta escuchemos
y mi respuesta a la pregunta estamos ya
en una recesión mundial va a ser no no
en este momento eso no significa que
esté descartada hemos rebajado nuestras
proyecciones de crecimiento para este
año en abril para 143 países esto es el
86% del pib mundial y desde entonces en
un corto periodo de tiempo un poco como
el tiempo aquí en davos el horizonte se
ha oscurecido estamos viendo este 2022
va a ser un año difícil tenemos un shock
de precios de las materias primas en
muchos países y el shock particular
sobre el que quiero llamar su atención
es el de los precios de los alimentos es
food prize shop
otro de los temas y debates importantes
en este foro la alimentación global que
está seriamente amenazada por la guerra
en ucrania jorge bueno rusia y ucrania
dos de los principales productores no
sólo de alimentos sino también de
fertilizantes en el mundo se encuentran
en este conflicto y bueno las
consecuencias ya comienzan a
evidenciarse la crisis de alimentos que
se avecina especialmente para los países
de áfrica medio oriente y asia se debe a
que estas regiones dependen del trigo la
cebada y el aceite de girasol a precios
asequibles que provienen de ucrania pero
por la guerra los puertos se mantienen
paralizados esto también fue un tema
clave en davos para darnos una idea los
países en cumplir en conflicto
representan alrededor del 30 y el 20 por
ciento de las exportaciones mundiales de
trigo y maíz rusia por ejemplo
representa el 15 por ciento de la
producción global de fertilizantes
nitrogenados y el 17 por ciento del
comercio global de fertilizantes
potásicos estos son esenciales para la
producción de alimentos en otras partes
del mundo el programa mundial de
alimentos estima que 283 millones de
personas de 81 países en el mundo
enfrentan actualmente algún tipo de
inseguridad alimentaria aguda y otros 45
millones de personas están por cruzar la
línea de la hambruna esto dijo david
bentley quien el jefe del programa
mundial de alimentos no abrir los
puertos es una declaración de guerra a
la seguridad alimentaria mundial es así
de sencillo si conseguimos que se abran
los puertos no se resuelve el problema
pero se empieza a crear la estabilidad
del mercado alimentario volátil en estos
momentos combinado con todos estos otros
problemas a los que nos enfrentamos de
los que podríamos hablar todo el día es
una tormenta perfecta dentro de una
tormenta perfecta y si no conseguimos
abrir el puerto de odessa sólo se van a
agravar nuestros problemas porque
tenemos que conseguir que esos campos
vuelvan a ser operativos pero no pueden
conseguir que los silos se vacíen a
menos que consigamos que los barcos
fluyan es crítico absolutamente crítico
juego bueno siempre hay tiempo para
anuncios importantes como el que por
ejemplo dio españa de su inversión para
producir microchips qué más dijo allí
pedro sánchez bueno el presidente del
gobierno español dijo que españa inicia
una carrera de fondo para convertirse en
un referente en la industria de los
semiconductores españa aspira a crear un
ecosistema sólido para el futuro de la
computación europa y atraer grandes
inversiones a su país en este en este
sentido el plan es tan ambicioso que
quiere que españa el líder el objetivo
de educar el 20 por ciento de la
producción mundial de semiconductores en
toda europa escuchamos
hoy mi gobierno aprueba un nuevo e
histórico proyecto estratégico sobre
micro electrónica y semiconductores con
más de 12 mil millones de euros de
inversión pública queremos convertirnos
en el mejor socio de la industria en sus
esfuerzos por ampliar y diversificar la
producción de microchips para hacer
frente a la creciente demanda y a las
interrupciones de la cadena de
suministro
vance de cloro españa no perderá la
carrera por las tecnologías más
avanzadas al contrario queremos
situarnos a la cabeza del progreso
industrial y tecnológico y el proyecto
estratégico de semiconductores lo
demuestra un serio y compacto
muchas gracias a san jorge punto final
en la economía aquí en directo américa a
continuación kobe 19 la semana en
américa siga con nosotros